Madam President Shireen Williams joins
us hi Shireen hi Andrew thanks for
having me thank you for joining us so
i'm looking here at my magic computer
and i see Jerry Jones says that the
cowboys are going to throw the ball at
Richard Sherman why is he saying that
it's probably not a real good idea that
but they say they're going to move des
around and do what they do and if des
ends up matched against Richard Sherman
that's the way they'll go that he's are
their key receiver and so we'll see if
that's the case I don't expect him to go
after Richard sermon that whole bunch
but you know they looked at what San
Diego did a little bit and I think
they'll try to copy some of the things
Chargers did although the Cowboys
obviously are much better running team
than chargers on I guess my question is
why tugged on on Superman's cape when
Superman is anything but I sure I'm
violet like Clark Kent Richard Sherman
is quite the opposite he wants you to
challenge him and he wants you to tell
him that you're going to challenge him
no question it could be a good postgame
rant from Richard Sherman this week too
but you know Jerry he can't resist
himself either so he's going to talk and
he's going to challenge people and and
if it turns out his way he's going to
talk after the game it didn't turn out
this way he's probably still going to
talk after the game so we got some good
postgame rant here between Jerry and
Sherman after this one's over do the
Cowboys shireen really think that they
can run the ball against the Seahawks in
their building yeah I think they do
think that it you know they did also a
good job against JJ Watt and I think if
you watched him play last night against
the Indianapolis Colts you realize how
good the Cowboys offensive line is that
they really a controlled wall for the
most part you know he had a wide open
sack of Rome oh that he missed on but
for most part the Cowboys did a great
job on him they think they can line up
in run the ball on anybody that's going
to be tested this week we all know that
but Bill Callahan told me yesterday said
we're not arrogant about it you know
we're trying to tell people what we're
going to do in line up and think we're
going to be able to do it but we do
think we can run the ball on anybody and
can run it well and they've done that so
far this year but
is their biggest test Shireen let's talk
big picture we know that DeMarco Murray
is on pace for 416 carries that would be
the most in the history of the National
Football League time Larry Johnson's
record when he was with the Chiefs if
you get to 400 you break down and that's
just a fact that that's a trend and
that's how it goes yet the Cowboys
according to our ian rapoport are are
offering an extension a four-year
extension to DeMarco Murray do they
think that at 27 next year he'll be 27 a
guy that's never played eight
consecutive games without missing one
for an injury is is worth a four-year
extension well they did it with marion
barber and they proved to be wrong in
that case so probably just depends on
how much guaranteed they're going to
give him and I yeah I would be surprised
if it's a lot I would be surprised if
DeMarco Murray accept anything why would
he until the end of the season and the
Cowboys Franklin shouldn't be often it
until he goes out and shoot shows that
he can play a 16-game season something
he hadn't done we know his injury
history he has a plate a 16-game season
yet and you're right 416 carries he's
going to break down if he has that many
carry this season the guy just can't do
you to go through the history books and
find all the guys who carry the ball
over 350 times and they break down and
it's not a good thing for him to do that
so you know you have to hope that he
doesn't do that they take some pressure
off of him Joseph Randle Jerry said
today is going to get more carries this
week we'll see they've said that
repeatedly the last two or three weeks
and it hasn't happened yeah I'll believe
it when I see it shereena you've covered
this team for how many years now uh well
I've covered that i guess i've been here
since 99 I've this my 21st NFL season
okay I mean I'm setting it up for a
reason the point is you know this team
you know this organization you know how
that town works you know how your owner
works I'm going to throw something out
there with no sources this is me
throwing something against the wall tell
me if it makes any sense Adrian
Peterson's a cowboy next year I think
that very well could happen if the mark
I don't think it's the Marco Murray and
Adrian Peterson I think it's DeMarco
Murray or Adrian Peterson and I think if
DeMarco Murray walks if somebody offers
some more money after the season and he
lives I very well think that could
happen I think Adrian Peterson could be
running back
next year and again there are so many
variables here obviously he is still a
Viking and he still has years left on
that deal he is still facing very
serious charges in Montgomery County
Texas I'm just thrown stuff against the
wall not predicting it just saying of
all the scenarios we could see that to
me is a scenario that might not be
likely but it wouldn't shock me that's
all I'm right there with you I think it
very well could happen assuming his
legal situation is done you know we've
seen that with josh brent they obviously
brought him back here we've seen Rolando
McClain they brought him in here you
know and they've had some good results
in the past with guys in trouble with
the law who could come in here and done
well they've had some go the other way
too but I think they would take a chance
on Adrian Peterson Jerry Jones thinks an
awful lot of him and I think that very
well could happen if everything gets
cleared nice on a Minnesota life anymore
and again that's way down the line just
yes making stuff up here so don't report
that I said that Shireen Williams fort
worth star-telegram know he got to get
to the locker room thank you as always
Shireen good to talk to thanks for
having me the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience